Die Hysterie rund um den Sexismus
kennt kein Halten mehr.
Die Feminismus-Bewegung
rast wie eine fehlgeleitete Rakete
durch die Gesellschaft -
und trifft dabei die Falschen.
Worum spielt ihr hier?
Um die Ehre?
(Lachend) Um die Ehre?
Das ist richtig,
wir spielen um die Ehre.
Tamara Wernli hat gute Karten in
der Hand und das nicht nur im Spiel.
Ein Pokerface?
Ja, ich lasse mir auch im Job
nicht unbedingt gerne
in die Karten schauen.
Denn ich möchte
die Leute überraschen können,
sei es mit Kolumnen oder mit Videos.
Ich hoffe immer, dass sie sagen:
"Das hätten wir nicht gedacht."
"Diese Meinung?
Das hätten wir nicht gedacht."
Es ist schön, wenn ich mal
was sagen oder tun kann,
was die Leute noch überrascht
und sie ein wenig
hinter dem Ofen hervorholt.
52?
- Ja.
Für die einen ist sie
ein antifeministisches It-Girl
der Rechten,
für die anderen eine unabhängige
Powerfrau mit spitzem Mundwerk:
Tamara Wernli.
(Mann) Come on!
Im ersten Spiel schon!
So geht das: im ersten Spiel.
Du musst gar nicht meinen ...
Die ehemalige Moderatorin
von Telebasel
ist heute eine prominente YouTuberin
und Star-Kolumnistin
der "Basler Zeitung".
Ihr Fachgebiet:
gesellschaftspolitische Reizthemen.
(Mann) Ja, ja,
kannst du jetzt wieder gehen?
Sie hat im Berufsleben
wie auch im Spiel dasselbe Konzept.
Sie ist auch im Berufsleben
ihren Konzepten treu.
Welches ist denn ihr Konzept?
Sie hat einen Plan
und geht auch nach diesem Plan.
* Dynamische Klänge *
Ich glaube, er meinte vielleicht,
dass ich einen Plan habe,
dass ich immer
noch besser werden möchte.
Dass ich ein grösseres Publikum
ansprechen möchte.
Dass ich auch mit
meinem YouTube-Kanal wachsen möchte.
Vielleicht
erkennt er einen Plan dahinter.
Aber ich habe keinen konkreten Plan.
Ich mache einfach und hoffe,
dass es gut kommt.
Er meinte wohl das damit.
Die Selfmade-Frau ist auf dem Weg
zu einer Podiumsdiskussion.
Das Thema: Meinungsfreiheit. Passt!
Wernli hat zu
praktisch allen kontroversen Themen
eine gepfefferte Meinung.
Auf ihrem YouTube-Kanal warnt sie:
"Nicht geeignet
für schnell beleidigte Gemüter."
Hallo, ihr Lieben.
Es ist gut möglich,
dass mir wegen dieser Worte heute
der Vorwurf des victim blamings
entgegenschlägt.
Vielleicht hält man mich
für emotionslos und frauenfeindlich.
Wer wegen
eines ungebührlichen Spruchs
in einen emotionalen Ausnahmezustand
gerät,
sollte sich Gedanken
über seine eigene Verklemmtheit
oder über
seine Selbstsicherheit machen.
Sie nehmen den Frauen
das Recht auf Selbstbestimmung.
Intelligenz wird durch Gene
mitbestimmt, Schönheit auch.
... feministischer Wächterrat ...
#MeToo-Debatte ...
... Weg in die neue Prüderie ...
ziemlich blöde.
Ich treffe jetzt Herrn Gracia.
Er ist einer der Mitveranstalter
der Podiumsdiskussion
heute Abend
im St. Galler Pfalzkeller.
Wenn ich ihn finde.
Dann werden wir hoffentlich
engagiert über Meinungsfreiheit und
political correctness debattieren.
Und darüber, was das heute
für die Gesellschaft bedeutet.
Hallo, Herr Gracia.
- Hallo.
Sie haben mich noch angerufen.
- Kamen Sie von ...
Von hinten, ja.
- Ah, ich dachte ...
Kann passieren.
- Schön, Sie kennenzulernen.
Gut gereist?
- Ja, danke.
Giuseppe Gracia, "Blick"-Kolumnist
und Medienbeauftragte
des Bistums Chur,
sieht die Meinungsfreiheit
in der Schweiz in Gefahr.
Seine These:
Wer mit seinen Ansichten vom
linksliberalen Mainstream abweicht,
muss mit Sanktionen rechnen
und wird von einer
selbst ernannten Elite therapiert.
Wir sind heute eigentlich
alles Patienten auf dem Podium.
Sie wurden so ausgewählt.
Der ideale Patient.
In dem Fall Kranke?
- Wir werden ja behandelt, oder?
Ja, aber wir sind
nicht krank in dem Sinne.
Aus unserer Sicht nicht,
aber alle Patienten sagen das.
Ja, das stimmt auch wieder.
Alle Patienten sagen,
sie seien gesund.
Inwiefern
ist Tamara Wernli eine Patientin?
Sie wurde
in dem Moment eine Patientin,
als sie den Mainstream
im Feminismus-Diskurs verliess.
Sie sagte,
es gäbe so was wie Frauen,
die tatsächlich
emanzipiert und stark sind.
Sie ist aber gleichzeitig nicht
mit dem dominierenden Gender-Diskurs
einverstanden.
In dem Moment
ist sie sozusagen draussen.
Eigentlich sind wir böse.
- Wurden Sie schon mal ...
Als ich den Feminismus kritisierte,
sagte man mir auch schon,
ich würde Hetze betreiben.
Ich gehöre also zu den Bösen.
Was sagten Sie dann? Also ...
Ich kritisiere
verschiedene Punkte des Feminismus.
Aber harmlos.
Ich finde: "Hey, wir müssen den
Frauen Mut machen und ihnen sagen,
sie sollten
Eigenverantwortung übernehmen
und aufhören mit der Opferrolle."
Das reicht schon.
Dann hetzen Sie.
- Ja. Ein Klassiker.
Das ist eine Wiederauferstehung
des Hetzer-Begriffs.
Hi, wie geht's?
- Hoi.
Mit Andreas Thiel,
einem weiteren Diskussionsteilnehmer,
ist Wernli in bester Gesellschaft.
Nach Gracias These: alles Opfer
der political correctness.
Zählen Sie sich auch zu den
Opfern der political correctness?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Ich sehe mich grundsätzlich
nicht als Opfer, nirgends.
Ich hasse diesen Opfer-Diskurs
und sich als Opfer zu bezeichnen.
Ich bin doch kein Opfer.
Ich kann überall das sagen
und schreiben, was ich möchte.
Und sie tut es auch: Gerade
in der Gender- und Feminismusdebatte
nimmt die Kolumnistin
kein Blatt vor den Mund
und trifft damit offenbar einen Nerv.
Es gibt zwei Arten von Frauen.
Die einen haben Spass,
sind mit sich im Reinen,
handeln selbstbestimmt,
strahlen Zuversicht aus.
Sie lieben das Frausein,
zelebrieren ihre Dekolletees
und die Weiblichkeit.
Die Anerkennung dafür
nehmen sie dankbar an.
Die anderen sind neidisch,
frustriert, hypersensibel,
dauerempört,
ärgern sich über Unterwäscheplakate
sowie über lustige Werbung.
Den Blick aufs Dekolletee
halten sie für sexuelle Belästigung,
ein Kompliment für einen Übergriff
und den Hostessenjob für Demütigung.
Diese Frauen wollen,
alle Bereiche abschaffen,
in denen sie nicht mithalten können.
Haben sie keinen Spass,
dann auch nicht die anderen.
Die Damen
faseln von Frauensolidarität,
aber das Wort Gleichschritt
wäre passender.
Denn ihr Verhalten liegt näher
bei diktatorischer Unterdrückung
als bei femininer Unterstützung.
Nur weil ich eine Frau bin,
muss ich nicht solidarisch sein
mit der Damenwelt,
die nun von ihren Erfahrungen
mit Weinstein-Typen
in den sozialen Medien berichtet.
Ich muss diese weder uneingeschränkt
glauben noch einstimmen
in diesen Kanon der Opfersymbiose,
der streckenweise überraschend
unreflektiert daherkommt.
Ich kritisiere den Feminismus
auf verschiedenen Ebenen.
Denn ich finde,
dass es den Feminismus,
so wie er sich heute präsentiert,
nicht mehr braucht
in unserer Gesellschaft.
Denn Sinn und Zweck des Feminismus'
war ja ursprünglich mal:
die Gleichberechtigung
zwischen Mann und Frau.
Die Chancengleichheit
zwischen Mann und Frau,
dass wir alle von Anfang an
dieselben Chancen haben.
Und das haben wir erreicht.
In der Schweiz,
in den westlichen Industrieländern
haben wir Chancengleichheit.
Jede Frau kann genau das Gleiche
wie ein Mann machen.
Frauenquote? Unnötig, findet Wernli.
Lohnungleichheit?
Grösstenteils selbstverschuldet.
Schliesslich würden Frauen
die falschen, schlechter bezahlten
Jobs selber wählen.
Zudem seien viele Frauen zu wenig
selbstbewusst und leistungsbereit,
um sich in die männerdominierten
Domänen vorzuwagen.
Wir müssen schauen, dass wir als
Gesellschaft weniger sensibel sind.
Es liegt wohl daran:
Alles ist schlimm.
Man ist immer hysterisch,
anstatt dass wir uns
zurücknehmen und entspannen.
Auch wenn ein Glas runterfällt,
nicht immer gleich ausflippen.
* Lachen *
Ich appelliere an die Leute,
entspannter zu sein.
Langfristig ist das wohl besser für
unsere Gesundheit und unser Leben.
Weniger Hysterie,
auch was die Sexismus-
und #MeToo-Debatte anbelange.
Das ist ihre Botschaft.
Und dafür kriegt sie
von der einen Seite Applaus,
von der anderen wird sie
als Anti-Feministin ausgebuht.
Auf jeden Fall polarisiert sie,
und das gefällt den Medien.
(Mann) Tamara Wernli, wie kommt man
von einer Schauspielausbildung
und vom Regional-TV dazu,
sich ins Rampenlicht zu stellen
als eine Art Hassfigur
bestimmter Kreise.
Gab es einen auslösenden Moment?
Ich stelle mich nicht als Hassfigur
für bestimmte Kreise auf.
Ich schreibe jetzt
seit etwa acht Jahren
regelmässig Kolumnen
in verschiedenen Zeitungen.
Ich könnte auch
einen Schmink-Blog eröffnen.
Denn erstens
würde ich dann mehr verdienen
und zweitens hätte ich keine Haters.
Aber nein, denn es macht auch Spass.
Ich betreibe
eine gewisse Art von Provokation.
Ich stichle ein wenig.
Wenn es negative Reaktionen gibt,
muss man damit leben
und gewisse Sachen
an sich abperlen lassen.
Vielen Dank.
- Bitte.
Ich habe auch Mobbing erlebt.
Ich wurde auch schon
nicht berücksichtigt.
Ich wurde ...
vielleicht auch schon diskriminiert.
Ich war auch mit
sexuellen Übergriffen konfrontiert.
All das habe ich auch erlebt.
Ich habe in meinem Leben
auch Scheisse erlebt.
V.a. auf der beruflichen Seite
ist einiges vorgefallen,
was mich sehr zurückgeschlagen hat -
jedes Mal.
Aber mir wäre es nicht einmal
in den Sinn gekommen, zu finden:
Die Männer sind schuld.
Selbst ist die Frau,
so Wernlis Devise.
Bereits vor 20 Jahren
machte sie sich selbstständig
und hat heute ihre eigene Firma
im Kommunikationsbereich.
Die Videos für ihren YouTube-Kanal
produziert sie in Eigenregie -
das Wohnzimmer ist auch ihr Studio.
Mhm, man sieht noch den Stuhl,
das will ich nicht.
Der Baum ist drauf.
Okay.
Die Gemüter sind nach Kavanaugh-Fall
noch nicht beruhigt,
schon steht
der nächste Vergewaltigungsvorwurf
auf den Frontseiten.
Die Schlinge liegt jetzt
um Cristiano Ronaldos Hals.
Meine besten Kolumnen sind die,
bei denen ich stinkwütend bin.
Bei den Videos ist es dasselbe.
Wenn ich mich zünftig
über etwas aufrege,
entstehen meist die besten Videos.
Die ausgebildete Marketingplanerin
und PR-Fachfrau
erreicht mit ihren Videos auch mal
eine Viertelmillion Zuschauer.
Seit ihre Videos
auf dem liberal-konservativen bis
rechtspopulistischen Online-Magazin
Tichys Einblick aufgeschaltet werden,
hat sie viel deutsches Publikum.
Und kriegt u.a. Zuspruch
aus dem politischen Umfeld der AfD.
Was sagen Sie denn, wenn
Sie aus rechten Kreisen Lob kriegen?
Es kommt ja
nicht nur aus rechten Kreisen.
Auch aus der ganzen Mitte kommt Lob.
Ich sehe ja, wer mir folgt.
CVP-Präsident Gerhard Pfister
mag meine Videos,
liked sie, retweeted sie.
Leute der FDP -
das sind ja alles keine Rechten.
Aber klar gefällt meine Meinung
sicher auch den Rechten.
Eben Schnittmengen.
Aber schlussendlich kann ich
nicht steuern, wer mich schaut,
wer mich gut findet
oder meine Videos retweeted.
Das, was ich zu transportieren
oder zu sagen versuche,
ist wahrscheinlich wichtiger, als
derjenige, der die Videos schaut.
Schreibt mir eure Gedanken,
ich würd mich drüber freuen.
Folgt mir auf Twitter
und macht Werbung für meinen Kanal,
wenn ihr mich unterstützen wollt.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.
So. Voila.
Wernlis Follower und Abonnenten
sind aktiv.
Ein Video von ihr
wird bis zu 2'000-mal kommentiert -
meist von Männern, und denen geht es
nicht immer nur um den Inhalt.
Ich finde jedes Kompliment nett.
Ich habe nichts gegen Komplimente.
Auch wenn es nur
um mein Äusseres geht. Es ist nett.
Die 45-jährige Baslerin
hält sich gerne in Männerwelten auf -
auch in diesem Spiel.
Oh nein!
"Call of Duty" wird v.a.
von jungen Männern gespielt.
Ich finde es einfach lustig.
Man kann rumspringen,
an den Wänden rum...
(Kreischend) ...klettern.
Haben Sie das gesehen?
Den hab ich super gekriegt.
(Lachend)
Ja, ich bin ziemlich angefressen.
Ich bin wohl die Oma.
Man kriegt immer wieder
Freundschaftsanfragen,
und ich denke immer: "Wenn die
zwölf- oder 13-Jährigen wüssten,
wem sie ihre Freundschaftsanfrage
senden ..."
Denn man kriegt
Einladungen zum Spielen und so.
Oder: "Wie alt bist du?"
Ich verrate mein Alter lieber nicht,
sonst spielt niemand mehr mit mir.
Die "Call of Duty"-Oma.
Als Einzelkind aufgewachsen - ohne
Politik und französische Philosophen,
wie sie einmal schrieb,
war Tamara Wernli Ende 80er-Jahre
als Sprayerin Jil
in der Basler Hip-Hop-Szene
unterwegs.
Auch das eine männerdominierte Welt.
* Gemächliche Klänge *
Meine Eltern haben versucht,
mir ein starkes Selbstbewusstsein
mit auf den Weg zu geben.
Sie sagten immer wieder:
"Wenn du willst, kannst du alles."
"Aber du musst es wollen."
Ich wollte früher oftmals nicht,
hatte nur Flausen im Kopf.
Schule und all das
wollte ich nicht so.
Aber sie sagten sehr schnell:
"Wenn du jetzt nicht willst,
wirst du es später
halt schwerhaben."
Ja, wahrscheinlich
hat mich das schon so geprägt,
dass ich heute versuche,
so viele Probleme wie möglich
selbstständig zu lösen,
bitte nicht um Hilfe und suche
die Schuld auch nicht bei anderen.
Ich versuche eher,
mich selbst zu verbessern.
Konsequente Eigenständigkeit.
Auch in der Ehe.
Wernli ist verheiratet.
Über ihren Mann möchte sie
in diesem Film jedoch nicht reden.
Die Rolle als Hausfrau und Mutter
kam für sie nie infrage.
Ich habe mich nie als Muttertyp
gesehen und wusste schon früh -
schon in jungen Jahren -,
dass ich keine Kinder möchte.
Vor Kurzem hätte sie eine politische
Karriere einschlagen können.
Die FDP Basel wollte sie
als Kandidatin für die kommenden
Nationalratswahlen gewinnen.
Wernli, die sich
als liberal bezeichnet, lehnte ab.
Sie wolle sich auf ihre publizis-
tischen Tätigkeiten konzentrieren.
Und sie lässt sich sowieso
nicht gerne
einem politischen Lager zuordnen.
Ich bin z.B. für die Ehe
und das Adoptionsrecht für alle.
Ich bin für Abtreibungen
und die Legalisierung von Cannabis.
Ich habe gar grüne Positionen:
Ich glaube an den Klimawandel
und daran,
dass er menschengemacht ist.
Ich versuche z.B., nur zweimal
die Woche Fleisch zu essen.
* Gemächliche, rhythmische Klänge *
"Postergirl der neuen Rechten" -
so wollte die Journalistin
Michele Binswanger Wernli
in einem ihrer Artikel
eigentlich bezeichnen.
Doch nach ihren Recherchen
und einem Gespräch mit Wernli
hat sie
ihre anfängliche Meinung revidiert.
Die beiden treffen sich nun
sogar regelmässig zum Kaffee.
Auch wenn sie das Heu nicht immer
auf derselben Bühne haben,
gerade in puncto Feminismus.
Wenn man von Frauen wie wir ausgeht,
macht man oft den Fehler,
dass man immer sagt:
"Für mich hat's geklappt,
wieso nicht für alle?"
Wenn man sieht - das passiert mir
oft, wenn ich Vorträge halte -,
dass Frauen mir
ihre Lebensgeschichte erzählen,
wie es ihnen ergangen ist.
Dann staune ich manchmal auch.
Dann denke ich auch:
"Ich argumentiere
aus einer privilegierten Situation
bzw. hatte
ein privilegiertes Leben."
Das ist nicht für alle Frauen so.
Für diese Frauen ist es wichtig,
dass sie Hilfe erhalten -
von Organisationen und Initiativen,
die sich
für Chancengleichheit einsetzen.
Ich finde die Botschaft,
die man jungen Frauen vermittelt:
"Die Männer unterdrücken uns,
das böse Patriarchat hält uns klein
und hindert uns daran,
unsere Chancen wahrzunehmen."
Dagegen wehre ich mich,
denn das stimmt nicht.
Wir sind keine schutzlose Rehe
oder hilfsbedürftige Geschöpfe.
Wir Frauen können
genauso stark sein wie die Männer.
Wir sind z.T. auch verlogen,
manipulativ und verschlagen.
Wir haben das alles auch,
sind nicht die Heiligen,
die Hilfe brauchen
von der Gesellschaft oder vom Staat.
Aber deshalb muss man
nicht alles über Bord werfen.
Wenn du sagst: "Wir sind starke
Frauen, haben alle Mittel" ...
Ich sehe z.B. Frauen,
die missbraucht werden,
die auch in Familien aufwachsen ...
Natürlich,
das ist eine ganz andere Geschichte.
Da kann ich nicht vergleichen
und masse mir nicht an,
über solche Frauen zu bestimmen
oder zu sagen, sie seien stark ...
Die Radikalen sagen, es sei
ein gesellschaftliches Problem,
ein Männerproblem -
dagegen wehre ich mich.
Wenn Sexismus vorkommt
oder Männer Frauen unterdrücken,
sind es Individuen, die das tun.
Aber nicht alle Männer
oder die gesamte Gesellschaft.
Ich finde,
hier muss man unterscheiden.
Ich finde, die radikalen Feministen
tun das nicht.
Auf Wiedersehen. Danke.
- Auf Wiedersehen.
Tamara Wernlis Spiel geht weiter.
Ihr Ziel: noch mehr Publikum.
Ihr Einsatz: Koketterie,
Provokation und Überraschung.
Anstatt an jeder Ecke das Böse
und den bösen weissen Mann zu sehen,
würde ich eher daran appellieren:
Hinterfragt doch auch mal!
Wenn es irgendwo nicht weitergeht,
sucht eine neue Lösung!
Bildet euch weiter, lernt,
wie ihr besser verhandeln könnt!
Denn bei Frauen scheitert es
z.B. beim Verhandeln im Pay-Gap.
Anstatt den Fehler bei den Anderen,
bei der Gesellschaft
oder bei den bösen Männern
zu suchen,
stellt euch auf die Hinterbeine
und macht selbst mal was!
Bäng!
Nein, falsch. Tanzen!
Nein!
Pirouette! Päng!